hallo
herzlich willkommen zur cellestis ich
bin auch der rolle woran ist auch dabei
heute gibt kein rezept videos sondern
eine anleitung für ein blumengesteck ich
habe die hochzeit meiner freundinnen
also die steht bevor und ich werden und
trotz dafür packen habt dreistöckige
torte geplant und möchte die gerne
dekorieren und ich habe mir gedacht ich
mach das mal was ganz anderes als
fondant und zucker deko ich mache
einfach mal eine echte deko die torte
ist eine eistorte und hier drunter habe
ich dann ein blumengesteck so wie jetzt
hier auf den fotos sehen könnt und heute
geht es in diesem video nur um dieses
blumengesteck also ich habe jetzt hier
am main etr scherb und zwar ist es
eigentlich eine tasche für vier torten
und wie gesagt verwende ich jetzt den
untersten teil für die blumen und das
ganze zubehör was die kids ihre wende
habe ich bei uns in graben-neudorf
geholt und zwar ist der blumenladen
schumacher das ist der blumenladen von
der lieben petra und dort wurde mir von
der nicole gezeigt wie man eben auch
diese geste gemacht und da gebe ich euch
jetzt ein bisschen die tipps und tricks
weiter und die dinge die wohnen wollen
dafür braucht ich bekomme jeden
blumenladen bis 20 müsste das eigentlich
haben genau mithalten blumenfachgeschäft
ja
da werdet ihr dann auch gut beraten also
falls das selbe machen wollte ansonsten
kann man auch so gesteck immer machen
lassen
also das wäre natürlich die einfache
variante aber ich würde es ganz hell
machen so jetzt habe ich hier also wie
gesagt dass erst mal auseinander gebaut
das ist auch ganz wichtig ansonsten
bekomme ich dass er gar nicht da rein
und jetzt habe ich hier drunter dieses
schaumstoff kranz und der wurde jetzt
vorher schon gewässert und das ist ganz
wichtig weil wenn jetzt die blumen da
reingesteckt werden würden sie ohne
wasserversorgung schon in zwei drei
stunden an warmen tagen sogar noch
schneller schon verwelken und so kann
ich das jetzt stecken und so gab es
übermorgen lagern wobei er wurde darin
wasser eingelegt genau und es sind jetzt
zwei grenze und zwar hab ich da unten
einen daten durchmesser von 40 cm hoch
sind
ja ich trete ich nutze man hoch also das
ganze aus ist eigentlich ganz leicht
aber dadurch dass es jetzt mit wasser
getränkt es ist etwas schwerer
und weil ich einfach eine schöne
rundungen haben möchte ich jetzt hier
noch mal 30 zentimeter krams drauf dann
lege ich jetzt hier hin und kann das
dann eben gut machen
jetzt möchte ich dass es hier vorne
etwas abgerundet wird das mache ich
jetzt hier mit einem messer es ist halt
ein bisschen sauerei zu hause aber das
kann man alles wieder sauber oder macht
einfach einen garten also hier einfach
die ränder bisschen weg
also je nachdem womit ihr das jetzt
gleich besteck müsste es natürlich jetzt
flacher oder etwas runder und größer
lassen wenn wir kommen später rosen
drauf und die stehen auch ein bisschen
ab deswegen schneide ich jetzt ein
bisschen mehr weg
es ist erst mal fertig da fühlt sich
auch so weit ganz rund
und vielleicht noch als kurze info wenn
der kranz einmal nass ist muss er immer
nass sein
also man kann ihn ruhig auch öfter
verwenden aber muss dann immer noch zeit
denn wir jetzt einmal austrocknet keine
flüssigkeit mehr auf jetzt muss ich den
oberen kann weil es eben zwei sind noch
befestigen und zwar nehme ich dafür
jetzt etwas trat das können einfach mit
einer zange abknipsen und dann umwegen
also wieso eine haarnadel jetzt
befestige ich denn von ihnen dann
rutscht da auch nicht weg
jetzt muss ich erst mal so eine erste
schicht drüber machen damit man eben
diesen kampf nicht sieht dafür nehme ich
jetzt hier so weinblätter aber diese
nicht fv als auch kann man keine
türkische star david machen und da muss
ich jetzt hinten so ein bisschen
wegschneiden dann mit dem stiel hier
reinstecken und damit auch flach anlegt
wieder mit dem draht mit einem kürzeren
draht einfach befestigen
mit die blätter einfach überlappend
darüber legen
für den übergang nehme ich jetzt diese
ranken das lege ich jetzt hier als
übergangen und muss später dann auch
nicht mehr soviel mit den blumen
auffüllen
ich starte jetzt mit den blumen ich
nehme sie erstmal die hortensien dem
hinweis und später kommen eben noch die
apricotfarbenen rosen mit otto und die
müsst ihr jetzt hier unten erst mal weg
knipsen und zwar den stil so lange wie
möglich lassen
und die sind jetzt noch zu groß deswegen
schnell sich hier noch weg und da am
besten immer schräg anschneiden damit so
viel fläche wie möglich da ist die blume
eben auch viel feuchtigkeit aufsaugen
kann
jetzt könnte sie entweder so direkt rein
stecken oder nimmt nochmal draht und
verstärkt das ganze dann ist auch beim
stecken das ein bisschen einfacher
er führt es jetzt einmal hierdurch dann
umknicken
und dann mit dem einen draht 23 warum
unter den der gewünschten länge
abknipsen und jetzt kann ich die so
reinstecken
als nächstes die rosen dran die muss ich
jetzt hier wegschneiden auch wieder
angeschrägt und daten steht jetzt auch
nicht zu lange machen
je nachdem wie weit ihr sie eben auch
rein stecken wollte und die könnte jetzt
so nehmen die haben relativ stabilen
stecken und künstler einfach irgendwo
rein stecken und es sind übrigens auch
die rosen die die nadja in ihrem
brautstrauß haben alles passt dann auch
alles zusammen
die platte liegt noch immer mal drauf um
auch zu gucken ob ich die richtige höhe
und die richtige form
nämlich noch schleierkraut und werdet da
mehr ist die lippen so ein bisschen film
kann man sich aber wegschneiden und dann
rein sprechen
jetzt finde ich eigentlich schon fast
fertig ist dann einfach mal ein bisschen
weiter weg gehen und gucken wo noch was
fehlen könnte wenn wir viel sitzt
nämlich hier noch ein bisschen was da
ist ein bisschen flach und so ist der
blume bekannt ist eigentlich schon
fertig ich muss denn jetzt noch über
nacht kühl stellen weil ich die torte
erst morgen fertig stellen morgen ist
die hochzeit jetzt muss es am besten in
den kühlen raum mit etwa 12 15 grad und
am besten einfach dunkel also ich werde
bei uns jetzt in den keller stellen
kühlschrank war zu kalt und mich
wirklich freuen wenn ihr zum beispiel
auch mal so einen blumenkranz nach macht
wie gesagt habe ich mein werkzeug und
die blumen alles in ärger bekommen im
blumenladen schumacher bei der petra und
ihr bekommt es natürlich auch bei euren
blumen fachhändler vor ort
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal bis dann
spiel